what up [ __ ] boy corn Diddy I'm sorry
I regret everything that's happening hey
guys what's up if you will Jewish muffin
Zack if you're like what the try guys
have blocks now the answer is maybe some
weeks we'll be all those together some
weeks maybe me and Keith they'll go do
cute things together I had a dream last
night I had twins and we grew them in
one of those external wombs that there
are sciences of venting you and I had
twins this week just me I like this I
can spin around which is really fun oh
I'm getting dizzy
today's video is actually something that
I've wanted to talk to you guys about
for a while and a diagnosis that I just
got it turns out I have an autoimmune
disease it is something and that's I
know that sounds really really [ __ ]
scary I guess I should start off by
saying I am okay I mean I guess I'm not
okay but I'm gonna be okay maybe I
should tell you the story so I have been
suffering from something as long as I've
been making try guys videos no one has
known you have not known the try guys
did not no not even really my parents
doctors didn't believe me as you may or
may not know I think I've referenced it
in some videos I have chronic back
problems I had a lot of things in my bag
tightness here and every time I roll my
neck I get like some pretty intense
cracks I have had really bad back issues
basically my entire life I was going to
the chiropractor when I was 10 I had to
have like an arrogant homage backpack in
middle school when I say I have an open
body I'm not really exaggerating I hurt
I ate I get stiff it kind of started
before I went to BuzzFeed a lot of my
time would be spent to the computer and
I noticed I would just when I sneezed I
could feel the pain shoot from my back
through the front through my chest cage
it was like I basically if my back's
hand
that's where it hurts me
my friend Colin offered to do a yoga
video the first time that I did yoga
well I have footage I can show you
that's the craziest thing about working
at BuzzFeed is that like I have these
chapters in my life that I can go back
and be like let's go watches am I gonna
be in pain tomorrow
feel like I'm gonna be in pain I feel
like I'm just gonna be in constant pain
for the next two months the first day
that I did it it was like I opened the
portals to hell
day one of yoga um my back hurts
so much like so much it was almost like
the exercise was picking open a scab it
was it was it was unveiling the pain
that was underneath I have a bit of a
hypochondria and so whenever something
dogger day I'm like cancer its cancer
cancer so I told my doctor about this
painting he says that's not thing you're
good you're good so I started going with
IRA Proctor I decided it was time to go
to the chiropractor
we took an x-ray turns out I have
[ __ ] scoliosis that's what I
discovered I had scoliosis the first
time I can go back to doctors and say
aha I was right look I have this slight
curve in my back now for anyone who has
scoliosis they would be the first people
tell you that my scoliosis is minor it's
not because you would get surgery for I
tried a lot of things to help this I
changed my diet I even got this really
cool standing chair so it's this really
weird looking thing where you're like
leaning it's like a leaning stool and it
did actually help my lower back pain
though in reality my friends just kind
of turned it into a toy more than
anything
yeah so use that chair to this day it's
really good no that is not what this is
for so problem solved
not really the pain built to a point
where I couldn't sleep I woke up at like
4:45 in pain this was every night for
four months laying down hurt being in my
bed hurt I mean living hurt I'm talking
about I would wake up in the middle of
the night five times and all during this
I had him I'm working a full-time job
but when you're not sleeping it eats
away at you mentally I dreaded when the
Sun would set because I knew that my
pain was coming back now throughout this
process I told my doctor told my
chiropractor we had this kind of false
diagnosis of the scoliosis but the
scoliosis does not explain the pain that
I was going through I mean not not even
close the amount that I had I mean it's
like Boop it's it's nothing I had to
start saying no to things in the try
guys videos we did a wrestling episode
and I said guys I can't do that
I'm afraid that if I fall I'm gonna be
out I went to the doctor and I kind of
did a last a final plea I said I can't
stand this anymore I started screaming
good thing and I feel bad for the doctor
but I was like hey this can't continue
I'm losing my mind it's a terrible
feeling to feel like you know that
something's wrong with you and the
professional who decide to help you
doesn't believe you I started
questioning myself maybe the pains in
your head what a terrible thing to doubt
your own reality so the story the story
after this gets pretty quick I got
referred to a Rheumatologist and within
minutes the rheumatologist is like oh
yeah I think I know what's wrong with
you I'm like what what that's what what
are you talking about I had to go in for
an MRI which was scary
because at that point I didn't know what
was wrong with me he just referred me to
an MRI and I'm like oh god what is this
is terrifying if you've never had
they take your legs together so you
can't move so I'm in the parking lot and
I can hear the MRI machine above me this
is the sound I was listening to for the
past like 20 minutes listen it's really
scary I'm staring at what I guess is
this as a speaker for the life of me it
just looks like a shower head about this
big there's got you know little dots
going around it and you're staring at it
the buzzing starts and it's just
repetitive like there's a person walking
by me I feel weird I still I'm not used
to vlogging I feel like a crazy person
doing this
no he's riding a bike good for him
it turns out I have ankylosing
spondylitis it is a real mouthful and
super fun to say
ankylosing spondylitis affects under 1%
of the population as I understand it
basically my body attacks the ligaments
in between my bones then the body goes
ooh I know I can fix that I'll put bone
there but bone is not supposed to grow
where bone isn't so I have bone growing
where there should be bone that causes a
lot of inflammation that causes a lot of
pain my hips had begun to fuse together
like in between the gaps of my hips
there's bone growing now getting a
diagnosis of an autoimmune disease
should be you know one of the worst days
of my life right but and I say this
honestly I was so [ __ ] relieved I
really was I mean I wanted to cry of
happiness because getting that diagnosis
was the difference between being able to
continue my life and not this was about
four months ago I am happy to report
that since that time I've been on
medication and I have felt better than I
have felt since like childhood I had no
idea so I take a drug called Humera
so no matter where I am no matter what
I'm doing I have to stop what I'm doing
and give myself a little shot you really
get poked we hold on to Zach's medicine
I have to take this medication twice a
month at the same time so it's 8:40
and I gotta take this shot have you guys
seen this before Eugene you've seen this
right so this is a shot so you put that
whole thing up your butt that's crazy
yeah so I really I just grabbed the fat
of my belly and I Eve I have to do it in
different places you do it on your butt
I wish I'm not allowed to it's pretty
easy
taking off alcohol swab you know just
disinfect the area that was overkill
whoo you know your shirts on it
damn it absolutely what's great is that
you never actually see the needle oh all
right
that's nice see this window right here
some you know it's gonna pop out of it
oh that's it I'm done all right then now
you put the rest of it in your butt yeah
now actually I did would you mind I got
you yeah I'm good at this what would you
do if Keith wasn't it hurts but nowhere
near the pain that I was living with
every single day so let's wrap this up
what's what's the takeaway here if you
were suffering you deserve help and you
deserve people to believe you and you
need to go out there and get the care
that you deserve and if you're in a
place where you have pains that you
can't explain or you know something is
going on but other people aren't
believing you do not take no for an
answer because I took no for an answer
for way too long and I didn't have to so
what's this needle tastes like I
wouldn't know where to lick it taste it
Oh also this is the most important
question we'll ask of the videos try
guys fans you are Triceratops horn the
homie we all know that but zack fans i
might give you corn buddy's corn babies
those are some good options if you got
another one let me know
gasps start to all right Corey buddy
take it easy I'll see you later bye